so business is really heating up your
users are downloading the app
viewing your web pages clicking and
tapping is it ten times a second
thousand maybe it's a million you're
likely searching for a messaging service
to help you capture these events and
turn them into valuable features and
analysis
stay tuned because in today's episode we
are helping you evaluate the multiple
messaging options available
including pub sub to make your decision
easy
[Music]
all right so you are ready to make your
event data accessible
and useful be it for automated machine
learning based recommendations
or even just basic reporting building a
data pipeline
is what will enable a smooth flow of
your source device data
to your data warehouse or downstream
applications
the data pipeline automates ingesting
transforming
storing and routing data to its
destination
a pipeline looks something like this
with a front-end landing zone for
ingesting the data
a continuous processing system such as
data flow apache spark or one custom
built for transforming the data
and finally a data warehouse to store
and make the data available for
analytics
or for routing data to a downstream
application
in this video we are focusing on the
ingestion layer of data
pipeline and breaking down your options
so that you can make the best ingestion
service decision
for your use case when you collect data
from devices
each device will connect to an api
front-end
these front-ends might buffer data into
blobs
before moving them to a blob storage
service such as google cloud storage
or hadoop's hdfs buffering is critical
to the performance of these systems
but what if the idea of buffering a
large number of events on your front
ends
sounds risky or if you need that data in
real time
in this case you need a messaging
service to land your events
as they happen google cloud offers
messaging services that support
streaming data
pops up pub sub lite and confluent cloud
you can also run apache kafka yourself
the easiest way to handle messaging is
pub sub
as we've discussed in this series pub
sub is a service
built to make messaging just work
whether you send one message a day
or millions a second with pubsub you
create a topic
and publish messages to it from anywhere
in the world
anyone who needs to read these messages
creates a subscription
and sees all messages in one place no
matter where they originate
the readers and writers can scale
independently and have their own coders
so any team in your company that wants
to do
something with that data can just have
it and for those
writing processing applications pub sub
has one
important trick you can handle each
message independently allowing more
flexible parallelism
than you get with partition based
systems
overall this means that you simply don't
have to worry about
how your messages are ingested once you
teach your front end
to publish to pubs up of course it's not
just about ingestion
for large-scale stateful processing such
as pipelines that aggregate data into
sessions
or join multiple streams as well as
scalable connectors to databases such as
bigquery
and bigtable pub sub is integrated with
data flow
data flow is its own story but suffice
it to say
that you can create an auto-scaled
pipeline
pushing data to storage with a few
clicks
in the ui or write complex processing
logic
in java python sql and other languages
and have data flow run the code reliably
for you
there's another cool thing that puffs up
can do which is
supporting message delivery to web hooks
natively
so you can do lightweight but highly
scalable data processing and forwarding
in cloud functions app engine or a
custom app you run in gke
pubsub does a lot so it can be expensive
for some use cases
as an alternative pub sub lite provides
a cost effective service for real time
data streaming
working with pub sub lite has some
notable differences from working with
pubsa
first light has single zone data storage
rather than multi-zone as in the case of
pub sub
second light relies on partitions or
shards to achieve
parallelism and horizontal scaling this
is less flexible than pub subs model
of per message life cycle tracking and
third
with light you pay for the capacity
reserved for your partitions
whether you use it or not so there is
some
operational overhead to optimize
capacity planning
a bonus of light is that it will be
familiar to kafka users
in fact there's even a client library
that implements the kafka client api
this similarity also allows us to
provide an integration with apache spark
structured streaming
which is commonly used with kafka like
pubsub
light is integrated with data flow for
processing
it does not however offer push delivery
to web hooks
speaking of apache kafka no discussion
of real time streaming is complete
without it
so your options include running kafka
yourself
or using confluent cloud a managed
service
from the founders of kafka running kafka
yourself
is flexible and can be very cheap in
addition
kafka comes with a rich ecosystem of
tools that are simple to deploy
connectors to databases such as bigquery
but
operating kafka requires a substantial
commitment to administration
confluent provides all the benefits of
kafka ecosystem
with managed services and support when
you choose between kafka and pub sub it
is worth considering these factors
familiarity and existing software if you
already have experience
running kafka as well as applications
that rely on it
it may make sense to just stick with it
availability outside of google cloud if
you're planning to run a multi-cloud
system kafka may be a better choice
since it is available on virtually all
platforms
integration with google cloud now pub
sub is a first party service which means
a consistent authentication
administration
security features as well as consistent
support experience
access control when you have multiple
teams or companies that need to work
with the same data
pub subs resource level access control
and administration system
can be very helpful in addition to a
flexible sharing model
you also get independent quota and
billing even between readers and writers
to the same topic
in addition you don't have to think
about different clusters
of popping up there is only one
global pub sub service unpredictable
growth
now one of the advantages of pubsub is
that it does not make you commit to a
fixed capacity
be it cluster size or number of
partitions
this won't matter much if your workload
is steady
but if you are growing quickly or see
spikes in the workload
this model is very convenient so
what's the tldr when it comes to picking
a service to ingest
and land data use google cloud storage
when extremely low cost is high priority
and freshness is not the downside is
that you keep more data
on the front ends risking data loss and
complicated scaling
for real-time streaming options within
google cloud you have puff sub and pub
sub lite
puffs up is truly everything that you
need for most real-time cases
integrating seamlessly with other google
cloud services
pub sub aims for a no ops experience
with automatic scaling and pay for usage
rather than capacity
however because pubsub does a lot it's
not the cheapest messaging solution
when it comes to cost efficiency pub sub
lite delivers scalable
real time messaging at low cost
like pops up it has good support with
apache beam
and spark for processing and will be
more familiar to kafka users
it is however not entirely no ops
you will have to manage your own
capacity and there you have it the top
tools and characteristics to consider
when building out your data pipeline
hopefully we've made it easier to pick a
messaging service for your event driven
workload
which one of these messaging options are
you using share with me in the comments
below
and ask us questions on the pubs up
discuss list
thank you for joining us today on pubsub
made easy
[Music]
you